so on this channel I often talk about
all kinds of alternative training
methods and attributes things like
training your balance like training your
one leg strength like training even your
vision however for many people the
foundation of performance is strength so
for a moment let's focus on that on
building strength how do you build pure
power like the Incredible Hulk
so most people to come to this channel
often will understand the basics of
strength training when you're training
for strength you need to lift heavy
weights this is the said principle
specific adaptation to impose demands do
the thing you want to become better at
if you're lifting a heavier weight say
up to 90 percent of your one rep max or
even slightly higher then you need to
reduce the number of repetitions you do
progress reasons because you physically
can't do that many 90 percent is the
point at which you recruit the most fast
twitch muscle fibers however you can
still grow and develop muscle at 75 or
even 80 percent of your one rep maximum
using something like 75 to 80 percent is
particularly advisable for beginners
because you're not going to completely
fatigue your nervous system and some
people even advocate using a slightly
lower amount of weight like this when
you're training at advanced levels in
order to see how many repetitions you
should be performing with these
heavyweights we can look at something
like Pepin's chart here we see that for
instance if you're doing 90 percent of
your 1 rep for maximum then the ideal
number of repetitions you should be
doing in total is 4 to 10 but you can
only do one to two repetitions per set
so you need to do lots of sets in order
to accommodate that as you increase in
strength of course you can lift more so
you can increase the amount of weight
that you're moving this is called
progressive overload and of course it is
one of the core building blocks of any
strength training regime the other basic
principle when it comes to strength
training is that you'll be using big
compound lifts the reason for this is of
a compound lift such as the deadlift
such as the bench press uses lots of
muscles together in order to exert more
force if you can exert more force that
means you can lift heavier weights and
if you want to get stronger then lifting
more is the objective at the same time
this teaches your body to use those
muscles all together as a single
cohesive unit and that in turn means
you're more functional you can transfer
that strength more to the real-world
training programs like strong lifts 5
times 5 are built around these
principles and are a great starting
point if your main goal is to build
strength in those key lifts however if
we really want to be super strong like
The Incredible Hulk then of course we
want to take things a little bit further
first of all we want to define strength
there is of course a difference between
absolute strength and relative strength
absolute strength is the total strength
that you have the amount of weight that
you can shift relative strength on the
other hand is your strength to weight
ratio we can also divide strength into
max strength also called limit strength
which sounds awesome starting strength
and strength endurance and these three
different things describe different
facets of your strengths so max strength
that's the peak amount of force you can
generate at any given point I have a
starting strength in some ways is more
important for athletes this is the speed
at which you can generate a huge amount
of force and there's a kind of
acceleration curve you have strength
endurance which of course is your
ability to exert strength over a
significant amount of time now imagine
that you're an Incredible Hulk and
you're holding up the roof what
everybody else is escaping and how long
you can hold that for that's your
strength endurance it's no use being
really strong once so how do we train
these things well there's a few
different methods which of course I'm
about to share now if you want to
improve your starting strength then you
can use something called the dynamic
efforts method and this is going to
improve our rate of force development
which is that initial burst of the
starting blocks do this we're going to
be using slightly lighter weights and
we're going to be focusing on the speed
at which we go through the motion the
ideal amount of weight is 50 to 70
percent of your one rep maximum so for
instance if you normally benchpress a
hundred kilograms you're going to take
50 kilograms and they're going to
perform the movement but you're gonna
focus on going as fast as possible and
exploding through that movement I really
like what Ross Edgeley says which is to
imagine that you're trying to launch the
bar through the ceiling but of course
don't let go you'll be banned from your
gym when you do this you're using
something called compensatory
acceleration in other words you're still
producing the same amount of force he
would be for the heavy weight but now
some of that is in the form of
acceleration rather than just lifting
that amount of weight and what this
should do is to improve your neural
Drive for that you can recruit two
muscle fiber more quickly improve your
rate coding so they're firing faster
thus giving you the speed initially in
the movement if you've improved your
squat a huge amount but you haven't
improved your vertical leap then using
this kind of training could be what's
missing that and you might also be too
heavy which is why you can also use
plyometrics the west side the barbell
system which is where the dynamic
efforts method comes from recommends
doing two days of max effort heavy
weights and two days of dynamic effort I
just recommend that if you are doing
some kind of training program focused
purely on strength on the big lifts that
you maybe do incorporate at least one
dynamic effort day in there or just use
the mind muscle connection to really
focus on exploding through those
movements sometimes another way we can
increase our muscle fiber recruitment is
through ballistic isometrics i've talked
about this before basically you're doing
in over
i symmetric i means you're pushing or
pulling against something you can't
shift for instance loads too much weight
onto the bench press so you can't lift
it then use the rack to have it low at a
point where your arms are bent to have
it in your grip now you're going to
attempt to press it but obviously you're
not going to be able to do it ideally
you want to contract for six seconds
each repetition and you need to go
through three different joint angles so
you're gonna have it lower around the
middle and then arms nearly extended and
the reason for this is that isometrics
only effect thirty degrees of the joint
angle range of motion ballistic aspect
of this means that you're going to be
trying to burst into that movement
you're gonna push as hard as you can all
of a sudden and you can do this in a
kind of pulse method safe burst into the
movement hold it another burst another
burst and of course what you're doing
here is telling your body to recruit
those big muscle fibers in order to
generate that force and acceleration of
course nothing's going to happen but
it's the intent that creates that
important connection this is something
that Bruce Lee used and the old-time
strongmen used and it's fantastic for
building real power was the isometrics
on the other hand and slow eccentrics
are useful if you want to build that
strength endurance so strength endurance
is not quite the same as muscle
endurance it's not quite the same as
doing high repetitions with a lower
weight not the same as bodybuilding
style pump training although of course
there's some crossover what we're gonna
be doing it's gonna be using heavy
weights till seventy to eighty percent
we're gonna be doing more volume per
session and we're going to be reducing
the recovery time in between sets this
will allow you to use more muscle for
longer and more frequently but what I
also recommend doing is slowing down the
actual movement and one way you can do
this is with very slow eccentrics
because the eccentric portion of the
movement the lengthening of the muscle
normally the part we are putting the
weight down that's where you're
strongest and if you think about the
example of Hulk holding up the roof
what's he doing is preventing his
muscles from elongating he's fighting
against the eccentric portion of the
movement so by very slowly lowering
weights they're extremely heavy you can
build up your strength and endurance and
exert force for longer and quasi
isometrics take this concept to the
extreme by challenging you to perform a
range of motion taking about a minute to
do so so of course it gonna really drop
down the weight now you might even just
use your body weight you're gonna do
something like a pull-up or a squat and
you're gonna take an entire minute or
even longer to perform the whole
movement and what this is going to do is
it's going to improve your mind muscle
connection
feel yourself moving at the same time
it's gonna make sure that there's really
no points of weakness in that motion if
you go through a squat normally using a
heavy weight and fully explosive
movement and you can actually use
momentum through quite a lot of the
range of motion that means that if
you've got a sticking point a weak area
you can just power on past it and never
have to deal with it if you slow things
right down you can really feel your
technique all the way down and you can
feel where you're weakest and this
allows you to work on that thus making
you much stronger overall finally one
other technique I recommend for
improving your max strength in
particular is heavy partials so
extremely heavy partials mean that
you're taking a really heavy weight and
then you're moving it only through a
very short range of motion and one of
the exercises best known for this is the
rack pull here you're going to set up a
barbell as though you're gonna do a
deadlift you can have it raised off the
ground on the rack now you're only
pulling it a short distance and the
reason for this is that you're teaching
yourself to lift extremely heavy weight
can't lift that weight for the entire
range of motion but you are able to lift
it just that short distance and at the
same time having the rack there means
that you're less likely to injure
yourself now there's some people that
say that this has something to do with
overriding the Golgi tendon organ which
basically turns off the body's safety
switch there's no concrete evidence to
say that this is what's happening
however what certainly does happen as
you develop your grip you develop the
supporting muscle so that you become
better at the movement and you build
your confidence and that's huge because
it's scary being under a huge extremely
heavy amount of weight you might drop on
your face or your chest if you use a
heavy partial you can practice this in
the safe environment where injury is
very unlikely and then when you come to
do the movement for real it's much
easier and you're much better at doing
safe after destiny is someone who of
course has been championing this for a
long time so if you want to learn more
about them then I reckon he's probably
your best source of information finally
the other question to ask is strong
where because you can be extremely
strong when it comes to deadlifts and
squats and bench press for those all
movements in the sagittal plane they're
all going straight up or straight out
and that's only a portion of your
strength at the same time many big lift
programs programs that focus on those
common compound movements will leave out
important aspects of your training
leading to imbalances and issues for
instance athlean-x of course is always
talking about the importance of face
pulls and
similar exercises to train the external
rotation in the shoulders this movement
if all you do is press and pull then
you're never actually doing that motion
and thus it becomes weak now some people
say what doesn't matter I'm not training
to be functional I'm not a functional
athlete I want to be strong but actually
that is strength I learned this the hard
way when I went to the gym with a friend
maybe a couple of years ago now showing
up trying to massively beat him on every
move because he didn't work out
regularly with weights in the same way I
did and then we came to the reverse
flyes and he just wiped the floor with
me and I just looked useless this is
strength so if you want to be strong you
can't just neglect some aspects of your
strength likewise you want to be working
on your obliques on your ability to talk
when we were working on cross body
movements on your grip on your neck
strength and if you do all that then you
become far stronger in every angle and
from every position now no one can push
you over now you can lift someone by the
head with one hand that's probably
something the Hulk would do
you're not only strong in certain lifts
if you're really interested in becoming
a power lifter then of course training
just those movements that's perfectly
reasonable but if you're interested in
strength for the sake of strength for
performing like the Incredible Hulk
then I highly recommend that you add
these kind of accessory movements to
your program in order to make sure that
you're plugging all the holes and doing
everything you can be to build strength
at every angle and every speed
calisthenics will help with this a great
deal and of course old time strongman
training these guys knew about this
stuff they were constantly lifting
really wide bars they were pressing
things over one side of their body with
one arm even had a lift called the
anyhow lifts where they just had to lift
a weight anyhow these guys train their
grip they used overcoming isometrics and
in many ways they were really strong
over the closest thing to the Incredible
Hulk
hope you found that video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like share it around and
subscribe to the channel let me know in
the comments down below why I missed
what strengths tips you guys have as
many of you know I do have a book that
incorporates all this kind of stuff
along with things like mobility balance
training plyometrics explosive training
etc so if that sounds cool then check it
out the links in the description down
below it's called super functional
training and of course we're getting
really close now to reaching 100,000
subscribers which is extremely exciting
so thank you so much for all the
support to all of you and stay tuned
because there's going to be some
celebrations along the way I've got some
cool videos coming and a couple of other
interesting announcements as well so
yeah it's gonna be a big week next week
thanks a ton for watching this one and
I'll see you then
bye for now